is the one I ain't like really [__] with
yet feel like I didn't have much to add
to the app you're making a big mistake
my man the only currency for all those
businesses and your music is attention
before you can sell or get somebody on
they got to be listening and the
enormity of attention on Tik Tok bro I
went on Tik Tok when it was called
musically it was that early and you know
what the first content was business talk
I went on Instagram and did this when
nobody was doing this people were taking
nice photos of the skyline I went in and
did my thing in the room I didn't give a
[__] what the room was doing you're
giving a [__] what the room is doing go
on Tik Tok and make Instagram videos and
let it work out bro you are too
ascending to be silent on the MTV of
this generation